all right Bam Bam uh where'd you grow up
where are you from originally Los
Angeles California what what part Los
Angeles California ain't no such thing
as a South Central
California ain't no such thing as a
South Central Los Angeles that came by
based on the 92 ride they created that I
was born in Los Angeles California on
the east side got it tell me about your
family growing up I came up in the two
parent household father worked at former
John for 45 years mother was a
supervisor of a bank Security Pacific on
Florence navalon they're from the south
my parents is from
Louisiana how old are you now 63
63 how' you grow up how would you
describe your childhood oh man I had the
perfect childhood I played Little League
Baseball P one football L le basketball
and all that my father was my first
baseball coach uh
uh went to verbon day went to Hopper
Elementary from there I went to Edison
then Willer Brook Junior High and
Compton ninth grade I went to verbon day
Catholic School right all boy school I
ain't like all boy school so I got
kicked out for selling
weed plus I was gang banking went to ya
in
1974 what what is it about the whole
gang thing that appeals to a kid who
comes from a great neighbor you know
great childhood come from what yeah I
mean you said you had a great childhood
yeah I I'm just I'm attracted to the
streets I was attracted to the streets
and I knew Ramy Washington personally
the founder of Crips so I I was
attracted to the streets and I wanted to
be a [__] it was when I was coming up
cripping started in 19669 so I started
gang banging in
1971 right my mother and father didn't
know I was gang banging this was
something I was trying to hide from
there but I was always attracted to the
streets and uh
becoming a [__] was like a kid waiting
on a big wheel everybody wanted to
become a [__] and I joined the Crips in
1971 ran through a line at Willer Brook
junr
High I caught attempted murder in
1974 I shot a dude over leather
coat did four years in California Youth
Authority at got out 1978 a week after
my 18th
birthday I called a Rob I Rob Safeway
supermarket
I went to uh Penitentiary that's the
first time I went to the penitentiary
1979 I was in DVI Tracy gladi
School uh I end up doing like 8 years on
the 13 I came home stayed out 45 days
and called a double
murder killed two dudes that were
snitching they gave me 75 to life after
being down like 21 years I went down on
my Appeal on automatic rever veral they
said it was found out it wasn't me
right but they didn't release me I had
to they offered me a deal that I
couldn't refuse they offered me 30
years based on they had a law called day
for day I could have got out cuz I had
already did like 20 something years but
the judge said no cuz I had caught
prison term I used to IID had a lot of
assaults on CEOs in prison s Quin and
old fome when I first went to prison it
was a lot of racial tension race Wars
the Crips Bloods and bgf was fighting
against the Emy Mexican Mafia the ABS
and and I was deeply involved in that I
was deeply involved in that I was a
high-ranking member of the Crips in
prison
um after coming home I lost my my father
first and I lost my mother about two
about a year before I came home my
mother passed and I came home and I said
I wasn't going to never go back to
prison came home got a good job working
today
uh now I'm just out of here trying to
create peace in the black community and
Hispanic communities right uh when you
hear them say black lives
matter I don't believe in they they
slogan my life always mattered a lot of
us didn't understand that I was one of
them you know mean I thought gang
banging was cool I thought going to
prison was cool but it wasn't going to
prison wasn't cool becoming a gang
member wasn't cool cuz I I don't want
you to take this nobody take this wrong
way I was a clu CL clan in a black man's
body I was doing more damage to my
community than any other community I
exploited my community I was a minister
to
society and
uh it it's a hurtful feeling when you
reflect on it I remember when I called
my murders I talked to my
grandmother they got me a lawyer cuz I
was facing the death penalty special
circumstances and my grandmother had
told me she said I'm afraid of you and
that hurting me I started crying over
the phone got me W to cry now and I
asked my Grandma I said what you mean
you was afraid she said I wasn't afraid
of you I was afraid of the lifestyle you
was living cuz wherever I went I used to
always have my gun you understand what
I'm saying um and I
didn't I didn't care about nobody cuz I
ain't know how to care about my myself
you understand what I'm saying and once
I learned how to appreciate
me and care about me and love me I
know you got me I knew how
to love other
people and respect them and
uh my greatest joy today is that I'm
living my life the life that that I live
I'm I'm a bre I don't like
procrastinating I don't like being late
for nothing I like being on time I go to
work I supposed to be at work at 6:00 I
go to work every morning Monday through
Friday at
4:00 excuse me I just love my life
today
uh did all the time in prison give you
time to reflect and think about it made
me it made me it didn't give me time it
it compel
me prison is the creat a beast or it's
going to make a man say he's tired of
living what how he used to live and I
got tired of
living I got tired of sharing a shell
with somebody else I got tired of
pulling a curtain when I had to use the
bathroom I
got I just got tired of being in prison
I'm not an animal want to know what's it
like in the
zoo see with somebody in the cage go to
the zoo I'm not NE
what needs to be in prison now I ain't
saying everybody in prison is
perfect but 45% of the people in
prison is
innocent they're in prison because of
the color of their skin and a lot of
them don't understand that they're
political
prisoners you understand what I'm saying
I ain't just talking about blacks and
Hispanics even whites because of the
vicinity the environment they might have
grew up in they're political they called
trash right prison the system is
designed to make people like me and you
go at each other but in reality when
they put us in them shoe programs
security housing unit me and you start
communicating and find out we the same
person in one the only difference is the
color of our skin we all grew up the
same we all made our decisions game
banging is a choice robbing is a
choice I made a lot of wrong choices and
when I came home I found out I'd rather
take the Positive Choices instead of
take negative Chances with my life and
my life today Mark is
uh
perfect perfect but it sounds like you
learned to love and respect yourself I
did and that that sounds like the key to
yeah all of this that's basically that's
what it
is uh and I know my mother watched down
at me man
like and she proud of me today she ain't
never been
embarrassed but I'm finally getting it
like about 3 months ago I just turned 63
last week on the 1 I was told I wasn't
going to never live C8 well God have
different picture pointed for
me and I told my big cousin I said man I
want to apologize to you said what you
talking about I said all that advice
y'all gave me when I was little I don't
never want you to think it when it went
and went out the other I kept it I just
didn't know how to apply it in my life
when you gave it to me today I know how
to apply it in my life today I don't go
around things that I know it's going to
send me some places I don't want to go
today instead of bringing violence I
know to really walk away I can hurt a
person better by not communicating with
them I can hurt a person better by
saying hey I'm cool we a we ain't got to
do this cuz it's my life that matters
and I'm know one got control of my
life you understand what I'm saying I'm
never going to let nobody have power
over me again and I allowed that when I
was a young dude today I got the power I
only Rel languish this power to nobody I
had a
power I I subject myself to things that
uh I shouldn't have to and and my my
facial demeanor expresses that like I
wor wearing hats Mark should take the
hat
off but that's my monacle you know what
I mean you resisted yeah
but that's called
adjusting so I know how to
adjust
without negativity don't nothing come
out of positive don't create negativity
but positivity can come out of
negativity so I try to keep it on the
positive level instead of having it on
the negative level uh I'm not with chaos
I'm not with no form of confusion I
don't even like dwelling in any form of
confusion I like being happy joy and
free you know what I mean I never had a
drug problem I drink today I drink melas
and Stellar beers and Tequila I smoke
good cigars you understand what I'm
saying uh I finally had a
vacation took some my vacation time for
my birthday and got sloppy drunk right
now life is begins again I got to go
back to work and I went back to work
Wednesday so I'm loving my life how many
years were you in prison
37 37 ain't never going back I don't
have no kids but I got a host of great
nieces and nephews that love me and I
don't want them to know me behind prison
like my nieces and nephews their parents
did I want my great nephews and nieces
done understand that you ain't got to
make no mistakes I already made them I
already ran into that wall so I'm
telling you you can't run through that
wall see the streets wasn't built for
everybody more that's why they made
sidewalks but can't nobody beat the
concrete up the concrete going to beat
you up if you try to hang in them
streets them streets going to beat you
up they going to either send you to the
penitentiary or they going to send you
to the to the
cemetery you understand what I'm saying
and that's that's what I figured out but
what advice would you give to all the
young because gangs are still alive and
well in that life well gang gangs ain't
going to never die what what what I
propose to people is this if you're a
gang member and you're an active gang
member and you say you love your
community how can you possibly love your
community if you doing dry Buys in your
child if you giving your gang 100% and
giving your child lesser than 100% that
mean you're a dead be father gang
banging is for kids once you become a
grown man and once you become a parent
see the biggest gang is Parenthood but
parents lack in being parents cuz
they're afraid to ask people on how to
be a parent see I don't know how to be a
parent cuz I don't have no kids I ain't
know how to be a son cuz I drove my
mother and father crazy but they never
abandoned me never deserted me you
understand what I'm saying but what I I
found out
was is room for redemption in
everybody's
life if you just give yourself a chance
you going to do better so my advice to
any child black white green purple
yellow being a gang member thumbs down
if you love your
community you want your you want to make
your community a safe haven cuz the only
people can can destroy your community is
the people that live in your community
can't no outside people come and destroy
your community if you sitting up here
waiting on triing your thumbs Like Jesse
Jackson just the operation hope it's
been over with it don't exist it it
don't exist only thing existing is if
you got a plan execute your plan Do not
sit on your butt cuz if you don't sit on
your butt you can execute anything and
accomplish anything in life and that's
what I'm doing today is it that lack of
selfworth that yes that's is exactly
exactly the lack of selfworth I had that
in me at one time right and that that
lack of selfworth was when I was in
prison cuz I didn't care if I would have
got released but it's also what it
attracted you to the gangs and and
getting in trouble and all that no I was
just attracted to the streets I always
have never had a low
self-esteem see once I I was a born
leader but I did follow somebody from
every great leader comes a great
follower I did follow some I followed
Raymond I followed TIY I followed M
Thomas you understand what I'm saying
these dudes I knew
personally
but I wanted to build my own
identity now my identity I'm building is
saying that I you can turn your life
around you can eliminate and delete the
the negativity out your life and
creating up positive stuff in your life
you understand what I'm saying uh and
that's what I'm doing
today that's what I'm doing
today you know that's exactly what I'm
doing I love my life can't nobody ever
take my joy from me is it the lack of
role models that kids have
today yeah the kids have today it's a
lack of Role Models you got fathers that
just not in their kids' life I mean look
look at it you got these young young
Hispanics young whites and young black
kids wearing
tapers them ain't nothing but bangs
whenever you see a child with tapers
them
bangs when I was a kid the only person
wore bangs was girls these kids today
wear skinny jeans them is girl
pants that's cuz they seen that's how
they mothers was dressing cuz the
fathers didn't want to be in the in in
the child life kids ain't made by
mistakes they made out of purpose and
out of
love and and some mens don't know how to
stand up for their kids I got a lot of
my
partners I admire and
respect cuz when they became
fathers they stopped gang banging they
got a job now their kids is in
college some didn't
graduated I got two nephews that
graduated from college I got a niece
that graduated from Howard
University you understand what I'm
saying uh my family is a name of promis
in Louisiana we got a street named after
my last name in Louisiana DHA Louisiana
I had a great uncle that was the de of
Southern in the
70s I'm following the lead of them you
understand what I'm saying I had a great
auntie a great great auntie that started
the women forties at Howard University
El hedgman that's my great great aunt
you understand what I'm saying so I got
to follow the the right people instead
of not the wrong the wrong people and
that's what I learned in life you
understand what I'm saying that's what I
learned in life it's uh simply put
Mark I'm enjoying heaven right now and
I'm living it seems like there's a lot
more joy in your life now yeah I cry
when you see tears come up my eyes and
ain't cuz I'm sad I'm
happy I'm really happy I watched Antoine
fish and started crying I'm just happy
I'm just happy it's a pleasure to be in
in in your presence
you know what I mean they say
10:00 I was ready at 8 you you called me
early yeah yeah you know cuz I don't I
don't believe in
procrastinating I want to show a person
that I'm willing to show up and show out
it's a great quality yeah you know
that's how I am o b what what would you
say is the most important lesson you've
learned in your life most important
lesson
is to love
yourself to love
myself that was my most important lesson
I learned to love
myself that's great cuz it was at a time
I
didn't that was the most important
lesson
though all right OJ bam thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you
very inspirational thank you
thanks